hello everyone and welcome to another
game from around nine of the Gibraltar
trade wise chess festival here we have a
game between eleven Iranian and Indian
Grandmaster satura man Panna hepanza -
Ramon I don't think all of that his name
I think part of it it's his father's
name but not really sure so if any of
you know to share in the comments and
here we we can really see that you don't
really want to face a well-prepared 11
RM so let's see this game and at the
mall at the time I'm making this video
there are five players actually tied in
first place with one more round to go so
there's really no no telling who can win
this tournament
Aragon opens with C for the English
opening we have E six the iron core
defense g3 d5 Bishop to g2 and Knight to
f6 Knight to f3 D captures on c4 and
Queen to a4 check butcher blocks Queen
captures on c4 and c5 Knight to e5 we
have Quinta c8 and here there are a lot
of moves for white white can castle
white can play something like Knight
captures on d7 if he wants d3 is an
option but here are again plays Queen to
d3 and this this definitely looks some
looks like some sort of a home
preparation sorcery Knight the c6 was
played and here are in an immediately
placed in Knight captures on b7 and this
is probably the idea of Queen to d3 now
black has to capture with the night if
black would capture with the Queen then
after Queen captures and Knight captures
Aragon has this Bishop captures on c6
and after B captures he can play simply
d3 go night to a3 control c4 and develop
all of his pieces and attack the weak c5
and c6 pawn so that's probably the idea
of this Queen to d3 move so knife
capture some d7 Knight has to capture
and we have Knight to c3 Bishop to e7
Queen to b5 now you can see that this is
move 11 and Aragon already played four
times wood
Queen a6 we have Queen to a four that's
five times and night the d4 castles by
both sides and d3 now here you might
think an interesting move would be
something like b5 taking advantage of
the Queen via Nani for an a4 but
actually after this b5 move you can
simply move the Queen to d1 and after
the rook moves as its attacked an a8
from the bishop white simply plays a4
and after be for knife to e4 and it's
not really an accomplishment here for
black after Y develops the c5 pawn will
be a weakness
maybe it's playable I don't think I
don't think sudirman wanted to go for
something like this so after d3 9th to
b6 speaking the Queen away Queen back to
d1 so that's six moves by the Queen and
she ended up from where she came from
Rock to d8 Bishop to d2 and the Queen to
d7 now rook the c1 rook a to c8 both
players developing b3 h6 and King to h1
Iranian will soon have ideas of pushing
f4 and such and he doesn't want a scheme
to be mg1 on this perhaps dangerous
diagonal Knight to d5
we have Knight captures he captures and
III here a knight moves to c6 and Queen
to h5 and this is a it seems like a
lashing out move but it's it's actually
not it's really a useful move it
pressures the d5 square the bishop and
the Queen are now attacking it this
Bishop doesn't really know where it
wants to go it can't really go to f6
because you lose the pawn on c5 and it
can't go to d6 because then Queen or
Bishop captures on d5 so but that's only
a part of it the real threat is Bishop
to h3 winning the exchange here so we
have Queen to b6 getting out of the
bishops away and here our engine pushes
f4
we have a5 a4 now preventing v5 and roof
to b8 now Sidora mana wants to play b5
efore d captures on e4 Bishop captures
on e4 and b6 now g-49 to d4 and Bishop
to c3 and this is a very exciting moment
in the game as the real question is can
saterland capture the pawn on b3 well if
that happens let's say Knight captures
on b3 you get this Bishop to e5 now
attacking the Queen and also pinning the
rook let's say Queen e6 as you do have
to prevent those pawns there and now
comes Luke to e1 I'm the queen on e6
Bishop to d6 let's say and after Bishop
to c3 it's actually a terrible position
for black because black is losing a
queen the thread is Bishop to H so I'm
gonna check and there's really no way to
stop this only way you can't stop it is
Queen to d7 or c8 if you play something
like this then Y it is simply breaking
through with the g5 let's say 94 or
blocking the bishop on c3 but now comes
f5 Bishop to f8 rope to g1 improving if
you capture then f6 is coming you're
threatening checkmate on h7 after you
block this simply rook captures on g5
and it's all over
Bishop g7 rook can capture pawn captures
Queen captures and there is really
nothing you can do here Queen f7 and now
comes Queen h7 and pawn captures on g7
with check King g7 and now Bishop to d5
opening up a discover to check it
doesn't really matter even if you
capture the pawn then comes rook f1
check you win the Queen that way and
this is just one of the variations that
allows black to keep his queen for a
while so after this Bishop to c3 of
course you can't capture the b3 pawn
that leads to a terrible position for
black tournament ride f5 and this comes
with the idea that he wants to sacrifice
a pawn to stop are in a bushing those
pawns
G captures on f5 and now Bishop to have
six blocking
rock to g1 now as now you did stop the
pawns but now he opened up the G file
for the rook rook to e8
the district create might not have been
the greatest move as there's a pretty
obvious obvious threat of Queen captures
on h6 so you probably want to prevent
this King to h8 simply getting the King
out of the pin but even if King h8 then
rope G for other rook is coming to g1
tournament didn't want to play this
passive position so he tried an active
move let's say it's an active rook e8
Queen captures on h6 was played rugby to
d8 and now rooks e2 e1 here rook to e7
was played and here are again played
rook to e3 and in this position said
tournament resigned at the game why did
he resign the game
well Ireland's plan is pretty clear rook
to h3 is coming but that's not the only
reason you can't move any of any of the
black pieces you can't move the knight
if you move the night you get Bishop
captures and f6 this is winning you
can't move the Queen if you move the c6
discovered ecigs discovered by the pawn
if you move the Queen anywhere from the
6th rank than simply Queen captures and
f6 is winning so basically all you can
do is you can't move the bishop if you
move the bishop f6 is coming opening up
the light square bishop so basically all
you can do is maybe play some
meaningless rook moves and this will
allow our onion to to complete his
attack let's say we're up to a 7 rook to
h3 is coming that unstoppable
rook back to c7 and now Queen to g6
preparing to lift the rook all the way
to h7 rope to f7 now rook comes to h7
let's say rook d7 and here rook to e1 a
very important move as it will take
control of the file let's say rookie 7
countering this and now comes Queen to
h5 there is the threat of a rogue to h8
checkmate and there is no stopping this
this is just one line that can play some
more moves let's say Queen captures you
capture capture and now after Queen to
e8 check it's all over if you play King
to h7
which is the only other move other than
blocking with the Queen you get rookie
300 work age 3 is checkmate so
only thing you could do maybe Queen to
f8 but now simply Bishop to d5 check if
you go King h7 you get Queen to h5
checkmate if you go King h8 then you
simply grab the Queen and f8 and if you
try something like Rock f7 and simply
capture neither the queen or the king
can capture it King moves rogue do you
want check and I have to capture the
Queen it's making one no matter what
black does simply Bishop to g6 but
that's the thing I really like about
this game after this rook to e3 move by
our onion let me just find the move rook
to e3 after this move as the tournament
saw that there was nothing for him to
look for in this game and he decided to
resign although there is no immediate
crush but you know in in some 10 moves
there is 1015 moves and he saw that so
yeah that's the game like I said at the
time I'm making this video there are
five players tied for first place
Ireland here after winning this game
Kuro Nakamura Maxima sherrilyn Grove I
think Daniel dubov is there and also
Richard report so five very strong
players and I think maybe more can
achieve this great result of 7.09 but
not all games are over
so we'll see it's very hard to say
commentary commentators said that maybe
there is a chance we'll see a Nakamura
vs. are in a match in the final round of
the Gibraltar chess festival but as both
of them had white pieces today it
doesn't seem likely but you never know
it's the computer that does the pairings
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon